[Music]
good evening and welcome to the running
commentary yeah so I wasn't to keep that
gag going I was gonna have to cut my
suit down the middle I wasn't gonna do
that it's been a little while since I've
done a running commentary as a matter of
fact yesterday I ran the second of the
two half marathons completing what I was
actually training for in this blog
series but I've just been very very busy
and these videos have just um
sat unedited on my computer for a few
weeks so I do apologize for keeping you
waiting
given that the events have happened what
I'm gonna do with these vlogs is squish
them down quite a bit so this vlog is
gonna be the remainder of my training
before the first half math and the
cambridge half marathon and it's gonna
cover a few things I'm gonna cut a bunch
of runs because a lot of it is just me
running down the street looking sweaty
and being like yeah I think this is okay
yeah
however one of the if not actually the
most important runs that I did was the
one you're about to see which was
repeating the run that I was supposed to
do in Oxford which I bailed out because
my legs can take it right it's 8:30 on a
Monday evening I just spent six hours
streaming with the ox cast funnily
enough there's almost identical
conditions when I last did my long run
my nine mile run in Bristol so I'm
currently charging up my headphones I'm
gonna go and do ten miles tonight man am
I ready to not be looking at the screen
right I need to plan arica so the way
that I typically do routes is go on
Google Maps and work out like how long
it is between the two points by like
just clicking on the map and being like
okay distance from home to here I'm not
gonna show you where I live but I'll do
it a random location on Google Maps for
the idea because I want to not docks
myself but I'll do something like click
over here and say directions to here if
I'm walking that's gonna be how many
miles then at destination and just keep
clicking and keep adding points until
you get to the total you're looking for
so I need to find a 10-mile meeting
today how can that be I have a plan I've
not been able to work out a 10-mile
group which doesn't involve me going
over like a massive raise so what I've
done is Davout the five mile route but
I'm gonna run twice
plus two is four minus one that's pretty
quick mess okay I've got no music let's
go I'll check it in a couple of miles
three miles in forget this song and I
think to consciously throttle back the
calm until I just Ram it slower than
what I won
so I'm resisting the urge to just like
power forwards it's so far manageable
pace feel I can kind of warmed up now
he'll find oh good
just passed a lot wait MA that's five
miles so this time last long run
my legs are crapped out the moment fella
came in the main sequence what am i
doing during sport like swims or runs I
always think about it in terms of stars
like the primary recognition to begin
with and then go enter into a steady
state in the main sequence this feels
like this is the main sequence I'm just
burning he'll turn any hydrogen to
helium and generally just doing getting
it done I'm concerned about is the
supernova at the end or the collapsing
into a black hole you either go off a
cliff at the end or you explode in
intensity at the moment felt like it's
going all right
I have developed
stitch and my left side it feels like
someone's pulled the hook through my
guts now I think that's because I went
down a hill quite a steep hill a bit too
fast so slide back so down and it
doesn't seem to be so bad anymore just
trying to ignore it basically trying to
Freddy Kreuger it come on boys
keep that hydrogen going three-quarters
the way around the stitch they had
earlier it's kind of coming and going
otherwise though I've kind of not really
aware that I'm running some of the time
it's just kind of happening I want also
part of it so good pace could probably
take it a little bit quicker it's going
very well
oh it stills routine at this point we'll
see how long that lasts I get the
impression that the last bit especially
given that the bike final stretch homers
up a big hill
this last foots getting the most
difficult but so far yeah feel good so
much through the hills I'm now trying to
make it as much time as possible in the
long flat I felt good I cannot tell you
how important that run was my confidence
I needed that run so badly like I say
I'm gonna be cutting a bunch of runs
from this two-week period but one you
must see because it's where this video
gets its title from is the one with
pixel go so today in the running
commentary there is a special happening
because I oh my God where are your
trousers I am being joined by pixel go
for the
first one that we've done together in a
while her legs aren't feeling very good
it's allowed to see and we might have to
turn back but this is going to be a nice
gentle three-mile run in preparation for
the big one tomorrow
the last big run before the half
marathon where are your trousers
how's that for you
so good so if you wanna run tomorrow
that's right here pixel goes stretching
to a video over there I'm stretching my
calves down here on the stairs
tomorrow's give me the litmus test
tomorrow is the long run to me doing 11
miles if I can do it well tomorrow I'll
be ready for that my husband if I don't
do it well I'm gonna be doubting myself
a week so pretty clutch runs tomorrow
see how it goes
not just that run actually went quite
well for pixel girl basically she
decided that she wasn't gonna do the
Cambridge art with me her leg and knee
specifically just hurt too much it was
actually almost exactly the same problem
that I had last year that stopped me
from running it feels like that it feels
like our training has very much been
sort of mirror images of this year in
last year so yeah unfortunately I didn't
run the Cambridge Hough with pixel go
because obviously as of the time of
recording this it do happen which was
the reason I signed up to it and I'll
reason I got into this mess
you know entirely might for not blaming
her at all you know it was it was pretty
gutting really I know it was for her but
she had to prioritize her health
educators prioritize not completely
injuring her like because you know
something might have happened that man
she would have been really reduced to
mobility for quite some time so
definitely the right decision to not run
I however had to keep training and the
final week of training begins this today
is my long run this is the final long
run for the half marathon this is gonna
be 11 miles so I'm doing an Augmented
version of what I did last week which is
actually still this calendar week but
there we go I'm gonna do two five my
lips around town but I'm gonna add on a
mile to one I think it might actually
end up being close to 12 miles we'll
have to see not really feeling it this
morning so I'm gonna hope that my
motivation picks up all on the way but
this is the last chance I'm gonna get
to sort of do the distance before you
know the day so this is an important one
this is this is one where if I do it
well
my confidence with hi going in if I
don't do well today that's gonna really
make me nervous about this is coming
weekend three miles in definitely
feeling a bit more tired than I like
let's see how this goes a few more miles
in I'm not sure how far I felt like I've
settled into main sequence which hurts
more than normal but just trying to keep
going at a steady pace okay I can do
this I can do this
definitely in the main sequence now
likes a nice and warmed up add a sharp
pain in one knee but otherwise we're
doing this half way come on feeling good
huh okay about to join up with the loot
for the second time I'm noticing that
pain in my knee is coming back let's
replace the stitch from last time I
think they're both result of an
asymmetry in my gait but a bit late to
change anything about it now okay we
doing lost like 100 meters so I'm just
gonna keep walking to keep my legs
moving that felt great at the end like
last time you went to like a state it's
almost like beyond the steady-state it's
like whatever the opposite of the wall
is you know how like when people are
Americans they talk about the wall we
have to break through it this felt like
after boy there's no bars is the
relaxants like every warm bath and your
legs are just like moving you don't mean
have to think about it there's still
activity well oils and well fueled and
okay so that was actually like eleven
point nine miles I'm doing it from this
angle because I take my top off because
I am incredibly hot yeah that was longer
than I thought and it was fast that was
like I should put the time with on
screen now that's the time if I can make
that I'll do the heart in less than two
hours so I'm super super happy with that
yeah did it
so here begins the final few runs before
the first of the half marathons what I'm
gonna do today is the first I've never
done this before
I'm running without a headphones so you
normally run with headphones because I
get bored and because it motivates me
but for the Cambridge heart
actually not allowed because it's partly
on a course that's open so there's a
chance I could be hit by a car I'm not
allowed to wear headphones so I've got
to get used to running without them so
this is this might be very painful I'm
just gonna be three miles because pixel
go and I want to spend a bit of time
together and I eat before she has to
disappear and I have the stream so just
three miles but we'll see see how this
experience carries so about a mile in as
I expected I'm actually going too fast
because I don't have the alerts and my
ears telling me how fast I'm doing each
kilometer they should be playing for my
phone speakers I need to fix that yeah
going about 30 seconds per kilometre at
least too fast so he'll listen to the
breathing listen to the body bit more
it's not too boring though it's quite
nice this is really beautiful
bones it's nice to not have 80s metal
pounding in my ears about two miles in I
think I've stopped looking at the
metrics because I want to see
what my natural rhythm is about any
intervention I think it is gonna be too
fast but we'll have to see I'm beginning
to wonder if I've been doing it wrong
all these years because I'm really
liking running without HIPAA Hinton sad
dad always used to run I mean used to
run before that invented headphones but
you know they relaxed kind of a more in
tune with how I'm running
I feel fine like I feel like I've run an
appreciable distance but that was fast
that's fastest pace ever done on that
route for some reason it was like 200
meters shy of what I normally do I must
have a corner somewhere I haven't done
history for a while but yeah this was
faster and easier than I expected
I've run without headphones - the rest
of the week see how I do on a longer run
tomorrow maybe I'm actually gonna be
better in the cambridge half my thought
also for the million people who have
taught me I already have a foam roller I
have been using it after each run
I just haven't shown you wrong stop
looking at me weirdly I have a fight the
remainder of the two weeks was me
tapering down so I did a couple of runs
which were quite short but just keeping
me active keeping the legs sore moving
over the week I'm not gonna talk about
those because they were pretty boring so
the next bit of running you're gonna see
in the next vlog is the cambridge half
marathon featuring of course my costume
lots of you have commented that this
series has motivated you which is such
like amazing news like its life some
people have started running because of
there some people have been getting back
into running because of it which is just
amazing to hear if you've been inspired
by this have you taken any entertainment
from whatsoever I've extended the Just
Giving page for this fundraiser out for
a few weeks because I'm going to be
posting a couple more videos all the
money from this video series over the
Adsense is gonna be going into that
fundraiser so until the last video comes
out it will be open you can donate and
please do so if you take in any
entertainment or if you would like to
just support to amazing charities
Durrell and Dorothy house in bath it
would mean the world to me if you donate
even just one or two quid that these
videos get about ten thousand views like
I said in the last one there's a huge
surge of people donating which is
amazing to see and we're currently at
about 2.2 grand if we can get that's two
and a half that'd be incredible to be
able to donate that much amount of the
two charities
thank you to those of you who have
donated already if you've not already if
you can spare any money would be very
appreciated by these charities okay
that's it okay that's it for this time
you will be seeing another video in this
series in about a week about the
cambridge half which was a hell of an
experience thank you for watching if you
haven't already please donate to the
Just Giving
Buy
oh god I'm just oh uh oh my god no not
gonna say